It's Oscar time.
Sunday night
Hollywood will give
famous people awards
for what they say
are the
best performances,
but Oscars leave out
political actors.
Not fair.
Politicians deceive people just like
actors do
and some of their performances
deserve recognition,
if not Oscars,
at least a
Stosscar.
So here are this year's
Stosscar Awards.
The award for
Best Performance
by a
Rich Elitist goes to
House Minority Leader
Nancy Pelosi.
In her eagerness to
trash Trump's tax cuts,
she described
thousand dollar bonuses
as "crumbs".
Crumbs
that they are giving
to workers
to kinda put the schmooze on
is so pathetic.
The award for Best Performance
by a Democrat
goes to
San Francisco District Attorney
George Gascon.
After California legalized weed,
the DA promised to drop
3,000 marijuana convictions,
and he made getting them dropped
easy
on the poor guys sitting in jail.
The process will take no hearings,
people will not have to hire attorneys,
they will never have to come to our courts.
We believe that it's the right thing to do
and it's the just thing to do.
And speaking of doing the right thing,
the Stosscar for
Best Performance by the President
goes to the moment when
President Trump said,
"We have cut
burdensome
regulations
for every
one
new
rule.
Great.
I wish you'd cut the new rules too,
but I'll take what I can get.
After all, he also chose
Jeff Sessions
to be his Attorney General,
and Sessions wins
the Stosscar
for
Worst Praise for Government Abuse
for saying this about
asset forfeiture:
"I love that program.
Man we had so much fun doing that
and taking the drug dealers money."
So much fun?
Taking billions of dollars from people,
most of whom
never even got a trial?
That's a crime,
not good government.
Yet both parties like it
and that isn't even the worst example of
bipartisanship.
We have worked well together.
The Stosscar for the Worst Act of
Bipartisanship goes to
Senators Chuck Schumer
and Mitch McConnell
for their budget deal.
This budget deal
is the first real sprout
of bipartisanship.
I particularly want to thank my friend
the Democratic leader.
I hope we can build on
this bipartisan momentum.
No, please don't.
You've already added
billions to our
unsustainable debt
and cut
almost nothing.
Does any politician
ever
say no
to more government?
Well yes, one has.
Rand Paul
gets a Stosscar
for
Best Defense of the Constitution.
Paul demanded the NSA and FBI
get warrants
before they
spy on Americans.
Do we really want all of our phone calls recorded
and then have the ability of the government
to bring you in and ask
you questions about your phone calls
and if you're not perfectly accurate in
recording your phone calls,
you could go to prison?
All we're asking for is that
for Americans
the Constitution should be in order.
But the Constitution
bores people,
so spying on Americans
continues.
Next, the
Stosscar for
Best Democrat on Free Speech
goes to
Senator Elizabeth Warren,
who after joining left wingers and
vilifying a conservative
then said,
"I think it's dangerous
to suppress speech.
First, suppression can backfire
instead of shutting up individuals
with disgusting views.
It becomes a launching pad
to national attention.
Second,
suppression suggests weakness.
It makes us sound afraid,
like we're afraid
that we can't defeat
evil ideas
with good ideas.
Good point.
The way to fight bad ideas
is with
good ideas.
Unfortunately her ideas are usually
not good ideas.
And that brings us to the Stosscar for
Worst Performance
by a President.
That goes to
Narcissus.
No, wrong picture.
I meant
President Trump
for
bragging like a child in
tweet after tweet.
Don't misunderstand,
the Stosscar judges
love his tweeting
but some are
repulsive.
He's a genius.
He
ended the assault on Christmas.
And because he got strict
on commercial aviation,
there have been
zero deaths.
Give me a break.
He hasn't even
done anything
that affected aviation.
Finally,
just as the Oscars give out one lifetime
achievement award,
this year's Stosscars conclude
with an award to a politician
who consistently has
fought for liberty.
It's trillions of dollars we're spending on these wars!
Congressman Ron Paul
has taken every opportunity he can
to challenge
enemies of liberty.
I don't understand this division,
why you may defend
social liberty
and liberties
rather well,
but as soon as it comes
to me spending my money
and assuming responsibility.
He fought to limit
executive power.
Why don't we just open up the Constitution
and read it?
You're not allowed to go to war without a
declaration of war.
And he fought the
political bipartisanship
that's bankrupting America.
And we've had way too much
bipartisanship
for about 60 years.
Ron Paul deserves
several Stosscars
for
fighting for freedom.
Now my time is up.
That's the Stosscars
for this year.
you